You know what time it is.
It's time for sports in the morning.
LeBron James calling out reporters.
NBA superstar
saying that
there is a double standard
when it comes to how the media c
the controversy surrounding
Kyrie Irving tweet support,
supporting a documentary
deemed to be anti-Semitic
and the way the media cover
the photo that has emerged
of Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry Jo
among the crowd of white student
attempting to block black studen
from entering the doors of North
Little Rock High School.
This is in 1957.
Listen to this.
I got one question for you guys
before you guys live
I was thinking
when I was on my way over here,
I was wondering
why I haven't gotten a question
you guys about the Jerry Jones p
But when the
Kyrie thing
was going
on, you guys were quick
to access questions about that.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on,
And I only want you guys to say
when I watched Kyrie talk
and he says, I know who I am,
but I want to keep the same ener
when we're talking about my peop
and the things we've been throug
And
that Jerry Jones photo
is one of those moments
that our people, black people
have been through in America.
And I feel like
as a black man, as a black athle
as someone with power and a plat
when we do something wrong,
or something
that people don't agree with.
So every single tabloid,
every single news coverage is on
the bottom
ticker is asked about every sing
But it seems like to me that
the whole Jerry Jones
situation photo
and I know it was years and year
and we all make mistakes.
I get it
seemed like it's just been burie
under like, oh, it happened.
Okay.
We just we just move on.
And I was just kind of disappoin
I haven't received that question
from you guys.
Wow. Very powerful.
There he is.
Coy Wire is here to weigh in on
Coy. Listen, does he have a poin
He's saying there's a double sta
What do you think?
Well, Don,
I think it's clear that LeBron f
Jerry Jones
perhaps didn't
receive the level of criticism
or wasn't as held as accountable
as perhaps he should have been.
But I also want to it's importan
to note, Don, that
LeBron James is not condoning
what Kyrie Irving did.
He himself said that I hope Kyri
Irving understands
the hurt
that he caused to a lot of peopl
But his decision in LeBron
bringing up
this topic
unprovoked in the middle
of a press conference,
it's a microcosm of the hurt
that many black athletes feel,
that it's long been
the case that many black athlete
teammates of mine.
I know I can say that
they believe that
sometimes they don't receive the
They receive a higher level of c
and harshness
that than perhaps
their white counterparts do.
I do want to throw a soundbite
here, Don, to Jerry Jones
when he was asked about this pho
that came up.
Here's what Jerry Jones had to s
That was, gosh,
60, 65 years ago.
And a
curious kid I didn't know at the
the monumental
event really that was that was g
And I'm sure glad that
we're a long way from that
Don, I do also want to point out
that this is not the first time
that LeBron has mentioned the Co
just last month actually on a po
he said that,
you know, LeBron,
who was a longtime Dallas Cowboy
he said that he stopped
being a Cowboys fan back
during the time
when players were kneeling,
when Colin Kaepernick was kneeli
and LeBron said that people
in the front office of the Cowbo
organization were saying that an
who would do that
would no longer be
part of the organization.
Of course, Jerry Jones said that
his players would have to toe th
He has since softened his stance
in regard to that.
Jerry Jones has.
But it's clear that LeBron did
this, did not sit well with him
Jerry Jones
not receiving
the same level of criticism,
maybe not being held as accounta
as he should have.
Kyrie Irving,
he was penalized
five games penalty without pay.
He was dropped by Nike.
And so you can see
that's his former teammate.
He this is not sitting well with
especially when these reporters
are in front of him every day.
And they had the opportunity
to ask LeBron about it when they